All right, welcome to the program.
Much to discuss, so let's get right into it.
Donald Trump is starting to lose support with
white voters.
This is the one demographic group that at
least until recently, Donald Trump still had
supporting him.
We looked at a cross-section of polling a
couple of weeks ago and we saw Joe Biden is
winning the black vote.
Joe Biden is winning the Latino vote.
Joe Biden is winning women.
Joe Biden is winning the college educated.
However you want to slice and dice it.
Donald Trump's resistance line demographically
was white voters, particularly white men,
particularly uneducated white voters.
But unfortunately for Trump, good for the
world.
Donald Trump has lost some ground with white
voters relative to 2016.
And it could be could.
Right.
Depends on who votes.
Depends on whether votes are counted properly.
This could be Trump's undoing in November.
Let's look at some numbers in 2016.
Donald Trump won white voters in Minnesota
by seven.
And right now, Trump is losing white voters
in Minnesota by two.
That's a nine point swing against Trump among
Minnesota white voters.
In Wisconsin, Trump won uneducated white women
by 16 in the last election, and he's now losing
uneducated white women by nine.
That's a 25 point swing against Donald Trump
in Pennsylvania, where we have a lot of data
on this.
Biden and Trump are tied among white voters.
Trump won white voters in Pennsylvania in
2016.
But if you slice it down even further, Donald
Trump is struggling with Pennsylvania suburban
white voters.
And this has been a gradual shift.
First, it was the college educated white voters
that started to move away from Donald Trump.
Now you're even seeing noncollege educated
white voters starting to move away from Donald
Trump.
Now, to be fair and to be thorough.
There are some other slices where Trump has
improved since 2016.
So if you look at Pennsylvania suburban white
women, Trump's doing okay with them.
Voters who disliked both Trump and Hillary
in 2016.
Trump is doing okay with them.
But these are potentially significant problems
for Donald Trump.
Again, with a major caveat if everyone's votes
are counted.
Now, what's fascinating about this is that
as white voters have moved away from Donald
Trump, Trump has been more and more aggressively
throwing out sort of like red meat for white
voters lately, talking about saving the suburbs,
which has very racially coded language.
He's even lamented voters who have to live
around refugees and immigrants in various
parts of the country.
He did that at a recent.
I think it was Pennsylvania and North Carolina
rallies, if I recall correctly.
But regardless, white voters slowly moving
away from Donald Trump.
Now, will it be enough to make a difference
in the final calculation?
We don't know.
We don't know the the strategies that Trump
has left to actually win are dwindling.
One such strategy that Trump was hoping for
was announce a vaccine in October.
And unfortunately for him, two days ago, the
federal drug administrate, the FDA said that
they are making putting in place stricter
guidelines to approve a vaccine via an emergency
use authorization.
That's bad for Trump.
He's unlikely to get whatever boost he might
have gotten from a vaccine announcement.
Will Trump push for some emergency stimulus
checks right before the election?
I don't know that he even as the time I really
don't, particularly with the Senate going
into recess.
And just what is it, about 21 days, really?
Just three weeks.
So I don't know what Trump can do.
And my sense, particularly from Donald Trump's
recent refusal to commit to a peaceful transition
of power if he loses from Donald Trump's recent
revelation that we got about a strategy to
try to mess with the electors if he were to
lose.
My instinct is Trump's focus is no longer
on actually winning.
It's on having a strategy to plausibly claim
the results were rigged and to snatch the
victory from Joe Biden.
If Joe Biden were to win,